etonnant non connaissez-vous rien de
plus humiliant pour une grande personne
que d'être publiquement déculottée par
un enfant quand j'entends déculottée au
sens figuré ça va de soi pour ce qui est
des tentatives de détournement de majeur
peut-être moi confiance je sais me
défendre
en revanche j'entends grande personne au
sens propre trois fois hélas je devrais
dire 46 fois hélas mon expulsion
placentaire ayant coïncidé avec le début
d'un exode encore plus générale je suis
même une grande personne envoie de
tassement cli je le sens bien que j'ai
dépassé l'âge mûr l'âge mûr qui
finalement n'est mais que l'âge qui
précède l'oeuf pourri pour pouf
avant ces digressions de cimetière où la
grisaille givrés de cet hiver de merde
me pousse malgré moi j'allais vous
narrer comment je fus récemment humilié
que dis-je bafoués au plus profond de ma
vanité de mal à poil dur par un petit
garçon un petit suisse
oui petit suisse tous les deux tout
sucre et qui s'appelait hans et qui
avait 8 ans et demi au moment des fêtes
c'est à dire avant-hier un petit garçon
normal avec des cheveux tendre et des
yeux bleus parallèle je vais de déjeuner
avec quelques amis chez son papa un
suisse riches excusez moi je bafouille
un suisse qui fourni des rations repas
aux compagnies d'aviation dans le monde
entier un type bien ne me faites pas
dire qu'un confédération helvétique je
ne calembours points dans les alpes au
pousse café
en ce qui me tient pour un être
d'exception parce que je dis des gros
mots dans le poste voulu à tout prix me
montrer la décoration de sa chambre
c'était sur 12 mètres carrés du sol au
plafond et jusque sous le lit un musée
de l'avion avec tout ce qui vole plane
ou sombres depuis les biplans un certain
façon blériot jusqu'à l'invincible
navette d'artifice que vous savez
en passant par le brigade de pont et le
spirit of san luis du regretté lindbergh
enfin regretté de ma grand mère devait
sauter les chutes de bourges est donc
non seulement le petit anz m'expliqua
que son père avait naturellement aider à
sa collection d'aéroplan mais que
maintenant ce qui l'intéressait surtout
lui hand c'était les chasseurs et les
bombardiers quand nous fûmes heureux
d'être revenu au salon je félicite et le
gamin pour le stupéfiant de précocité de
son héros philly casanière tout en
étonnant tout de même de sa nouvelle
attirance vers les machines de guerre je
m'en fous quand je serai grand je serai
pilote de chasse décréte at il avec une
pointe d'agressivité dans le pont est
alors moi pauvre moralistes de café
tabac voilà-t-il pas comporté par un
élan de pacifisme moisi indigne du
responsable du stage raphia longue durée
de la maison de la culture de saint
jérôme deschamps voilà t'il point qu'au
lieu de me taire exalté hackers par les
brumes de mon davidoff mêler aux
effluves de la poire williams rv
volatiles recoins que je m'entends dire
que je m'entends dire que à pabos la
guerre est que ak qu'à la mitrailleuse
elle cassait vilain takata kaboom voyons
ans mon petit pote enfin ce qui te plaît
dans l'aviation
ces deux volets mais pourquoi veux-tu à
tout prix volet dans l'armée c'est bien
ce que ça représente comores à venir un
pilote de chasse
sais tu que ça peut tuer un pilote de
chasse et lui poliment surpris en suisse
humiliés
[Musique]
etonnant non